Okay, so we just ran some queries on our list of 25 links by hand,
and that was a little tedious, so what are some of the downsides of querying data by hand?
Now, I know we only had 25 links there,
but one problem is it's very error-prone.
You have to write code for every query you want to answer,
and if you don't get the sort order right or something like that,
you have trouble.
It's tedious.
I could ask you a lot of questions about--
get these links sorted by this and that and links submitted by this user and that user,
and writing a function for each of those can be a bit tedious,
and one of the most important reasons is it's slow.
Now, you didn't see that yet because we only had 25 links,
and iterating over all of those links sequentially wasn't a problem.
There's only 25 links.
But if there were a million links or a billion links,
you wouldn't want to do that, or you wouldn't even be able to do that.
I wouldn't have even been able to build that kind of fake database in memory
like I did there, so databases basically exist
to take big chunks of data, like our collection of links,
which could be in the millions, and answer queries on them
in a reasonable amount of time without
having to write a lot of custom code, which is always an option.